are you looking for more uses for those  joy Kahn's well I've got a surprise for  you  I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news update  and for all the latest Nintendo news be  sure to subscribe the Nintendo switch  joy Kahn's pair using Bluetooth  technology which means you can use them  with a bunch of different platforms  including PCs Macs and Android devices  iOS however has its own specification so  this setup won't work with any of your  iPhone games that said it should be fun  to play new steam releases with  Nintendo's black and neon controllers  just be sure to map the correct button  presses the Nintendo switch is out now  which means just about everyone is  playing the newest Zelda and if you need  a few tips check out our video on the  nine things breath of the wild doesn't  tell you for all the latest on Zelda  Nintendo and everything else you're  already in the right place  [Music]